[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
[Applause]
you know what I was reluctant to get in
my vacation but that that makes it
worthwhile I was in Hawaii was so
relaxing until the missile alert came in
right on the phone did you see this [ __ ]
not a drip not a drill sory where could
I get new underwear but you know
Hawaiians are so laid-back you know
people who were to sew it on their phone
they just swipe left I saw one guy he
texted new phone who it is but happy new
season Happy New Year its Thank You 2018
on the Chinese calendars the year of the
[ __ ] I don't know well you know
think about that look I'm going crazy
already it's oh but just think about
Donald Trump he just says [ __ ] hole
everybody laughs at that and it's a big
day but actually changes real stuff
because that was the immigration deal
they were trying to do and saying [ __ ]
hold torpedo did and now they're gonna
shut down the government were waiting on
that right now live Friday night because
Donald Trump you know he wants to change
the immigration process he says why
can't we do immigration more like the
way I got Melania by using a catalog
he actually said that he said that we
should bring in more people from Norway
and today Norway responded they said
thank you pass so now we have this
government shutdown looming and it is a
stalemate because the Democrats are not
budging on the dreamers and the Trump is
even more dead set about his stupid wall
because his chief of staff John Kelly
went on TV this week oh and he said
Trump on the wall was uninformed and
evolving and Trump was fierce he said I
am NOT uninformed and who is this John
Kelly
and what's evolution but I'll tell you
what evolution is Trump for two years
telling all his fans every time he got
in front of me it's gonna be a giant
concrete wall of actual wall 30 feet
high from coast to coast no no it's it's
a fence or cement a stream or a thin
sprinkling of cinnamon like you do with
ants you know but if there is a
government shutdown Trump says not to
worry pornstars will still get there
hush money so any other president this
would be enough to get him out but yes
Donald Trump only man ever by the way to
pay a porn star to keep her mouth shut
so and you know what mystery I'm not
even gonna say allegedly I've been sued
out I want to know in lawsuits with
Donald Trump so wait if I lose this one
I'd be one and one but and they paid her
one hundred and thirty thousand dollars
you don't pay some in that kind of money
if there isn't something there so in
2006 only months after Melania has given
birth to their son Donald Trump is
stooping this porn star who was also
cheating on her boyfriend and he knew
biggest used to go home with orange on
her collar but but the porn star she
probably has fans here
stormy Daniel stormy Daniels star of
young and anal oh to be young and anal
Young ganado trailer-trash nurses for
good will humping and porking with pride
too and here's what we learned from her
and her affairs with Donald Trump she
said first of all he didn't use
protection he said he'd only used a
condom of Mexico paid for it
gotta love Donald Trump he's the world's
biggest germaphobe won't shake hands to
raw dog with a pornstar no problem she
also she says he chased her around the
room in his tighty whities and when
Trump heard tighty-whities he said well
you mean my voters
and I love this part that he made her
lots of promises like he was gonna buy
her a condo but she knew he was a con
man who would never keep his word oh if
only the voters of Wisconsin had the
same perceptive abilities as a star of
working with pride - and so he chases
around the room in his tighty whities
that slightly she says they get on the
bed he starts kissing her and she says
to herself hug here we go but she's a
pro she powered through it she said you
know sometimes if you have to have sex
with a guy like Donald Trump you just
shut your eyes and pretend it's Harvey
Weinstein